what's up guys
Greg outlet here yeah and I'm Monnet my
net boy that's her name yeah most people
butcher it those those nice monnet my we
have known each other for years so I
would hope you were nothing I know but I
finally started looking you in the face
like a year to go or something get when
you like talked to me before huh
well moral of the story it is mo net boy
and one of the stories it takes
confidence to become a grown man that it
does I was speaking of upbringing 20
most messed up children's drawings from
a mr. nightmare we just did a try not to
laugh I think if this was a try not to
laugh we would totally nail it yeah
mm-hmm although that first picture is a
pretty horrifying horrifying but it's
funny
I think these days kids have said now
let's take it a step further and look at
some of the creepiest things kids have
drawn yeah the person posted this has a
cousin who babysits a child who's not
very fond of her this was what she found
on his desk hopefully she didn't bees a
biscuit again this picture is titled
when you're cut up while you're sleeping
I guess this brings up the question if
the kid was supposed to be the one
sleeping or the one doing the cutting in
this picture we see some kind of tower
titled crazy big tower and there's a
door on the side labeled suicide door
with a line of seven more injured
waiting to jump out apparently and
outside waiting for these suicide
jumpers is apparently some kind of lava
guy who will surely burn these guys to a
crispy painful death inside of the
building there's also some kind of giant
man labeled maniac man the next dormer
is much smaller victims what was going
on in this kid's head
you will die followed by a picture of a
small person speaking to some strange
orb like object under what appears to be
a cave or maybe a mouthful of
razor-sharp teeth about to chew them to
pieces
who knows it's good I wouldn't kill them
sounds like this kid is growing up in a
nice inspiration oh this is just a
scholarship it seems in this picture a
little girl and a parent have apparently
just committed a massacre in the coffee
shop for know what's wrong with people
cheering for them on the right whoa this
kid thought it would be fun to draw a
mutant manly mouse kids hey does that
like the look the girl next to me is
pretty
I collect her hair this one is actually
disturbing because the thought of
somebody sitting next to you is he gonna
cut him off your hair just to fulfill
her sick air fetish may also lead to a
collection of something much worse than
hair everyone starts somewhere a mother
family died on me by her seven right
daughter on a piece of Magadan the
mother asked the daughter if the taller
figure was supposed to be her but the
daughter actually revealed that the
figure was what her imaginary friends
looked like this kid has apparently been
taught that all atheists go to hell I'm
sorry is that meant to scare kids into
believing things this one is rather
disturbing as we see a child and their
father dancing about on his or her
mother's grave oh my even though it
seems to be happy about her death I has
to make you wonder what was going on in
this kid's life - not happy about their
mother so how they try to like it was a
mother about to maliciously run over her
husband with her car
malicious this could mean several things
perhaps the kids parents fight a lot or
perhaps the kid might be angry with his
father and this picture was only wishful
thinking this how you up see this one is
beautiful say be from the demonic house
phone
- the [ __ ] you Emily and Dai written in
the background you would think this
would be creepy enough but there's
actually a horrific background story to
this Oh God
when the parents asked the child who
Emily was he stated it was his dead
sister
this child did have a sister named Emily
who died at the age of five when he was
only two months old the cause of her
death was not disclosed neither was the
reasoning for the child's apparent hate
- his dead sister that he shouldn't have
known about a little girl drew a picture
of her family with the mysterious
unwanted guest on the right Oh Julia
asked for the picture beyond the fridge
her parents wanted to know who the
taking boy was all they could get out of
her was he's the one that takes people
away I would hate to be the unlucky
parent who found this one here is a
horrific scene in which the child who
drew the picture has seemingly mutilated
his family and currently has his hands
dug into his dog who has a gaping cut
open hole in his back and judging by the
smile on his face he's taking pleasure
from doing it she has posted on some
kind of mental health board and since
then the mother who posted the pictures
online stated that the boy was being
taken for therapy got a feel for any
parents who find something like this
yeah his child Joey
decided to write a letter to his
apparently thrower father seemed sweet
but Joey seems to think his father is in
hell if his father is in fact dead and
he assumes him to be in hell it has to
make you wonder if his father did
something to warrant the hate of his own
child but that wouldn't explain for the
love Joey another important find for a
parent of course the mother won't sungod
kids notebook when confronted the kids
sat with his arms crossed not saying a
word
hopefully this kid has been taken for
some kind of help as these kinds of
pictures can be some of the biggest
clues for future criminals killers and
like six-year-old boy have been crying
to his parents every night that
something would come out of his closet
at night and stand at the edge of his
bed his parents decided to humor him one
time and asked him to draw the thing
looked like
his drone sent chills down his parents
spines The Grudge like figure seems like
it would be enough to give a grown man
nightmares let alone a six-year-old boy
there also appears to be something at
the window so now is 20 of the most
messed up pictures drawn by kids
welcomes may seem innocent and even
comedic but there were definitely some
that were truly disturbing true
sometimes you can get an idea of what
kind of person a child is just from
their drawings sure you should judge all
children based on them well I'm gonna
have nightmares now you are yes was that
not I mean really creepy you don't have
children though no right but I know a
few kids yeah that's true that's true
what you used to draw stuff like this
not particularly although you know what
some of them I thought could have been I
don't know people with like popsicles
and things that the narrator just said
was blood yeah like at number 19 when
you're cut up while you're sleeping
is that one of your popsicle example
baby I'm emotionally cut up and he's
bringing him a big magnifying glass you
know I can yeah the kid was a deep
thinking wow she appraised and he would
have become a fantastic artist ah no the
18 the big tower suicide tour I like for
this one on the narrator said they jump
out and burn to a crispy crispy or
whatever like the word that he chose
made it worse yeah he like found a way
to like focus onto something and go
here's what makes this even more
horrible because if your mind allows you
to just go to this direction for a
little while you will discover that it
could be worse maybe nothing further
uh you will die um he's felt will wrong
yeah the kids felt well wrong we got
nothing to worry he gonna be torture oh
this is terrible if I caught a
leprechaun I would kill him whoa whoa
luckily you will never catch
at least it's of wait leprechauns aren't
real right I dated someone to look like
a leprechaun no they're not
I don't think this one's crazy the the
family and they're all hi
OOP I'm thinking they're getting cheered
up it's not funny but you got to think
it's he at least seems like he's
interested in bonding with his family or
sheep I forgot which gender it was true
and there is some artistic depth yeah in
the drawing some nice colors added and
they spelled the shop with a Z no it's
all coffee right this look they got
coffee rice but they couldn't get shop
down huh or maybe that was part of his
imagination he was part of his style
yeah this is there's something I I don't
know what it is but there's something
like kind of admirable about that drawn
nice detail girl next to me is pretty
collector II I used to collect girls
hair all the time was the thing I did
when I was little my brother used to
collect my hair and he said that Oh
gonna sell it oh god we thought it was a
real gold
oh that relationship increasingly got
weirder in three seconds uh but we were
like six ish uh-huh Oh
ish yeah just add that there's maybe
even the son was me and Dad dancing on
mommy's grave oh that is so mean oh my
god maybe their parents were hippies
yeah yeah let's be the narrator first
you know it's interesting the grave
looks like gravy it does is that
fascinating yeah is that supposed to be
the sky I was just looking at that it's
a bit abstract yeah a one-dimensional
grass in the sky it's like right where
the grass ends the sky but we really
like what John I mean it's scribbly but
grass meets the sky that's the horizon
line it's like basically this slide sean
is not video today
yeah I will kill you mom I would love to
see a movie based off this concept I'm
just saying I'm just saying not that I
support it but I think we can get a
pretty bomb slasher film out of it
how old do you think these kids are at
least three and a half could you imagine
having a child and then draw something
like this what if your child was like 21
injures on me like this that would be
even more to worry that was are more
capable of actually doing it Oh
stay in school be nice don't draw
alright alright
I draw things about John do you yeah
like whenever you like tries to correct
me on things I was always draw picture
of John I want to see that yeah usually
there's usually several pieces of John
in the photos Oh anyway John Oh enough
maybe for these children
yeah guys are new to the channel
subscribe today button right here Mon at
Moyo click that button for her right
there to go check out her channel sweets
nothing like Ruby eats where she teaches
us how to make delicious delicious
treats but you know vegans though some
stuff is vegan it's just overall help me
take to this yeah then okay but overall
healthy yeah
and I do it with my friend Jessie it's
so much fun she says she does it with
her friend no no yes that's it like a
friends joke
like the hell says do it and you still
think of that do it yeah I don't I just
just you
we have instagrams yeah and uh uh
Twitter's that we are so on top of and
Facebook pages yeah anyway guys really
hot in here
because my fan died it is and John John
is stressing me out ah okay now John's
got a lot going on he's going to
Cleveland oh oh you're going right come
on this huh he's leaving the state
he's leaving the state forever yeah
crapper
that's when parties go down that's when
people start celebrating that's what
Matt finally does happy that's not true
I love you John mone loves you too hey
do and yet my cats are starting to like